any safety tips because you're working
again with with safety tips um yeah so
here's here's a safety tip so if you're
if you're writing a screenplay and you
know you're going to have a lot of
action in the film make sure your your
main characters don't have t-shirts so
try and like try and so talk to costume
design until costume design like try and
get them like maybe loose fitting jeans
or like a full sleeve shirt or sweater
so that way anytime there's an action
sequence they can pad up everything they
can pat everything up underneath them
and if they really do fall or get
whacked or something they're protected
like football players so that's key but
if you got a guy and the rock can pull
it off the road the rock can wear a
tight t-shirt and like you know and and
maybe he could probably break a wall and
not even feel it but most people can't
do that so you have to make sure your
wardrobe is appropriate to the action so
that's that's kind of like just a simple
advice if you want to keep your Cal and
happy but if you don't keep them happy
I'm get hurt then yeah put them in
t-shirts and have them fight on cement
and they won't be very happy
you